الزيتون
لتعاون معه خلال هذه
الاسبوعين من المؤتمر وخلال العام المقبل
حيث ستكون مصر
لديها الرئاسه وهي المسؤوليه
وستسلم
الرئاسه لاحقا لدوله الامارات العربيه
المتحده
اشكركم والارنب بطلاق الاسئله
شكرا
لكم
على كلماتك اللطيفه واشكر فريق همم امانه
العامه التي عمله جاهدا للوصول الى هذه
المرحله همم
امين
[موسيقى]
ان اخذ اي من الاطراء الذي
وجهها الى الامانه العامه لانني لم اكن
معهم منذ البدايه لكن من الواضح ان العالم
عليه
[موسيقى]
جغرافيه صعب ولابد من ان يكون لدينا مساحه
السياسيه
امنا لنلقي لنركز على القضايا بين يدينا
ومنها المناخ والازمه المناخيه التي همم
نستطيع مواجهتها في عندها سيكون لدينا
فرصه
همم
اعمالنا وهذا يبين في هذه الاوقات العصيبه
كيف يمكن ان نتجمع من اجل صالح العامه
مجالات تجمعنا
الى اي حد من ذلك النفود
السياسي الذي يؤثر على التقدم الفنيه الذي
يجب ان نحرزه لك لكنني
اشعر بحماس عندما بدات بهذه المهمه قبل
اسابيع
واشيده بالرؤيه التي
توجب علينا ان نمضي معا
نحن معا لدينا معرفه وخبره وانا فخور
بالكون جزء من هذا وجزء من هذا الفريق
ايضا
ونحن نتحرك نحو التنفي
نكون اطراف داعمه
لنحقق اكبر قدر من الطموح من على مختلف
الصعود
وخلال
اليومين القادمين سنركز على
جزء كبير وهو التغير المناخي وسيكون
مشاركه من رؤساء الدول والحكومات واعتقد
ان 110 من الرؤساء سيكونون موجودين معنا
خلال الايام القادمه
برنامج الشراكه مع امريكا سيبدا يوم الغد
وسيعزز اتعون
المجتمعيه
لتحقيق تقليل انبعاثات
الغاز
وايضا لتصبح اقتصاداتنا بصمه كربونيه صفر
ونحن نركز على اهميه الطموح
والعمل
ملح
لمعالجه هذه الازمه من كل القطاعات وكل
المناطق وكل الدول وكل الامم وكما قلنا في
كل مكان وفي كل يوم سنبدل كل الجهود
الممكنه
امشي
ابدا
التقارير الاخيره فان الانبعاثات لا تقل
بسرعه
حقيقيه او كما نريد لكن يجب ان نعمل لي
الوفاء بالتزاماتنا ال القوه والمناعه هي
التي تحمي المجتمعات من التغير المناخي
التاقلم هو طريقه
الخسائر والاضرار قضيه لابد من التعامل
معها والوقت الحان لذلك
يجب ان تحضر الدعم الذي تستحقه لتحقيق
الوفاء
بالتزاماتها المناخيه
التمويل هو جانب مهم
واخيرا
الشفافيه والمسؤوليه هذه مسائل لابد من
تعزيزها لدعم الثقه والتعاون
وتحسين مساله مراقبه
التعامل مع الازمه المناخيه
معرفه مسؤولياتنا فان هذا الجيل الاجيال
القادمه
من اجلهم لجلسات بناء وناجحه شكرا جزيلا
انا مستعد لتلاقيه اسئلتكم
شكرا
لك ان تعرف بنفسك اول مؤسسه الاعلاميه
التي تمثلها
[موسيقى]
بالتالي ارجو استخدام الميكروفون لاننا
همم
نبضت عبر الوسائل التواصل المختلفه
الضوء
حول هذه المساله على الجدول الاعمال وهل
هذا يعطيكم امل اكثر من اجل تحقيق نتائج
عامه
وحلتارونا المزيد من الضوء في نهايه هذا
النفق
شكرا
عليه قبل اسابيع عندما بدات
المناقشات حول ان كان
اضرار والخسائر اذا كانت ستكون على جدول
الاعمال
ووضعها وبين ان هناك تقدم والاطراف تاخذ
خطوات
واتساب واتساب
مهمه على مدى اكثر من 30 سنه وحقيقه انها
موجوده
على جدول الاعمال هذا يؤكد اما
اهميتها وانا احط الاطراف ان تواصل
بهذه الروح
المناطق المشتركه او
الجوانب المشترك للاتفاق ونرسم طريق
الامام وهذه المساله يمكن ان تكون محدوده
بالوقت وهما رايناه خلال هذه الايام
بيمارس
النقاشات خلال الاسابيع المقبله
السيد الموجوده في الصف الاول
في هذه الدوره
التي لم الوصول اليها على الاطلاق ام هناك
اليه اخرى شكرا جزيلا
اكيد تعتبر هذه مساله بشكل نجاحا للاطراف
وللعمليه وهي حصيله
خلال العام الماضي
[موسيقى]
للوصول وتوصل الى هذه الارضيه المشتركه
هاي هاي
الى اين سيقضي لكنني ارى ان الجميع لديه
هذا الامل بان يكون هناك جدول زمني للتوصل
الى نتائج وهنا امل انا الاراده السياسيه
التي
ادت فينا فينا الى همم وضع هذه الماده على
الجدول الاعمال وان تكون هناك عمليه
مفوضات تفضلها الى استنتاجات المرضيه
لكنها مبنيه على مصلحه كل الاطراف وكل شيء
نقوم به يجب ان يكون همم على اساس الجهود
المشتركه همم
خارج السربه ونحن كا رئاسه نحاول الوصول
الى هذه النتائج
السيده في الصف الثاني تفضلي
السؤال للسيد ستيل العالم
ان ان الجميع يدرك عن
الوضع الجيو السياسي وطبيعات
الازمه الاقتصاديه العالميه
وضعت عبئا على
التاء الوفاء بالالتزامات
والوجوه والوقوف بوجه التحدي التحديات
ومستقبل
فهي مسائل مهمه
نخرج عن المسار همم طموح
في همم مواجهه هذا تحدي
والا
نستغل او
نجعل هذه الظروف الراهنه على انها مبرر
لنا لنخرج عن المسار مسار الالتزامات في
متذرعين بان هناك اولويات اخرى الا ان هذه
هي الاولويه الاولى لكل شعوب العالم
وراينا في هذا العام درجه تاثير ذلك على
شعوب العالم ملايين من شردوا
وقتلوا والحرائق همم بسبب موجات الحرف في
اوروبا والولايات المتحده والتابعات ايضا
على الخسائر الماديه كل هذا يجب ان يبقي
اعيننا همم مركزه على على
هذه المساله وان نرفع طموحاتنا ونصل الى
اهدافنا بصفر انبيا اثات
وايضا مساله التمويل ومساله المواء امام
مساله التمويل التي قد تجعل دول الناميه
لا تستطيع القيام بالعمليات المناسبه وهذا
سيجعلنا تاخر لا مجال لتاخر بل التقدم ان
كنا نود ان نحافظ على اهدافنا
شكرا شكرا
جلي الخشيه ان تكون هناك اولويات اخرى
تسبق اولوياتنا وعندما ننظر الى الكوارث
حولنا كلها مهمه لكن ما من
ازمه
بحد ذاتها تكون على نفس الاهميه
اللي كما هو التغير المناخي اااه
ازمه الطاقه
تنتهي لكن التغير المناخي مساله ملحه
وستزداد سوء
الضروره لان نركز ونعيش تركيزنا لذلك فان
هذا المؤتمر هو فرصه لنا
نعيد تركيز على ما يجب ان نقوم به كلنا
نعلم ما يجب فعله
وكيف ومن عليه فعله الان هناك ضروره لبناء
الزخم
والنمدي قدما هذه مساله يجب ان تكون صلبه
اعيننا نصفه اعيننا ولابد مناقشتها هنا في
شرم الشيخ
وهذه الخشيه
ستجعلنا نفقد يوما وسنه وشهرا هذا امر لا
نستطيع تحمله
وهذا تراجع مهما كان مبرره
فان
القطره في المختلفه عليها مضاف مضافه
جهودها لاننا يجب ان نصل الى مكان يجب
الوصول اليه مسبقا
السيدات في الصف الاول بالقميص الابيض
القصار والاضرار
ما هي
همم
المساله التي جعلت الاعضاء مترددين في
وضعها على جدول الاعمال والان
بعد ان وضعت ما هو الشيء الذي سيجعل هذا
هذه الدوره قادره على النجاح في هذه
المساله
بل هي قضيه لازمتها على مدى زي الشمس
همم
[موسيقى]
تنطوي على هذه المساله ووضعها على جدول
الامل الا انها استشعارنا خلال هذا العام
تغير في موقف
بعض
الوفود التي كان لديها تحفظات ربما هذا
بسبب
الزخم الذي بنيناه منذ باريس وجلاسكو
علينا المحافظه عليه
والاعتراف بان هذا يجب لا يتم الا بوجوده
اييه
من اجل مصلحه الجميع والمصلحه هي تؤخذ
بشكل متكافئ بين مختلف الاطراف علينا ان
نبني على ما وصلنا اليه
الايجابي باننا من وضع هذه المساله على
جدول الاعمال لابد من عمليه تشاور شفافه
وهذا سيكون الارضيه
للوصول الى اجماع
وقرارات مبنيه
هذا هو سبيل تحقيق الاهداف
وهذه هي الطبيعه همم
وان هذه المساله لابد ان تكون علاقه
الاولويات شكرا
والاطراف يمكن الان تجتمع وتحل القضايا
العالقه مهما كانت القضايا
وكما قلت هذه مساله ومؤشر ايجابي وبناء
الاختبار الحقيقي هو نوعيه النقاشات التي
تحدث خلال الاسبوعين القادمين والحكم
سيكون على جوده النتائج هذه قضيه معقده
جدا لكنها حساسه
الذي تطلبه هذه الماده على الاجنده هي
التعامل بوجه الخصوص مع مساله الخسائر
والاضرار
والقضايا المتعلقه بهذه المساله
المساحه اصبحت موجوده والاطراف بدات
النقاش فلنرى الى اين ستفضي النقاشات خلال
اسبوعين
في الصف الرابع
عمليه عمليه
اكبر الدول انبعاثا الولايات المتحده
والصين ماذا تريدون من هاتين الدولتين
ان يقدم لمساعده
التي تتعرض لاكبر اضرار التغير المناخي
قصه ياسمين
في
مسؤوليتها عن انبعاثات الغاز
من الواضح انه من خلال مندوب الدول كل طرف
يعرف ما عليه فعله وكل طرف يجب ان يتقدم
ونعرف من اين تاتي غالبيه انبعاثات وهي من
مجموعه العشرين مسؤول عن 80% من الانبياء
كما تساهم
85 من اجمالي
انتاج العالمي ماذا يعني انه لابد من
معالجه هذه المساله والعلاج موجود في هذه
المجموعه من المهم جدا ان تتعاون الاطراف
وكما قلت فان المساحه اصبحت موجوده في هذه
العمليه لهذه الدوره من المؤتمر فهي فرصه
لهم لكن في همم حال
عدم وجود تعاون وبالنسبه
الالتزامات الوطنيه كل دوله تعرف ما عليها
فعله وكيف تقوم بذلك
محمد يوسف الاذاعه المصريه ثواني لمعالي
الوزير سامح شكري وزير الخارجيه المصري
رئيس المؤتمر
حسنا فعلت مصر حينما تقدمت بطلب نيابه عن
القاره الافريقيه لاستضافه كوبا تون سفن
الجميع يعلم ان الحكومه المصريه تبذل
جهودا كبيره في سبيل تخفيف الضغط الخاص
بالتغيرات المناخيه عن القريه الافريقيه
في ظل تاكيد القاهره الدائم ان القاره
الافريقيه هي الاكثر تضررا من تاثير
وتداعيات التغيرات المناخيه في ظل ايضا
انه القاره هي الاقل في الانبعاثات
الغازيه السؤال الان معالي الوزير ما هو
نصيب القاره الافريقيه في كرتون سيفن من
حيث الدعم الخاص بتمويل او دعم
التكنولوجيا او التحول الى مشروعات
المشروعات الخضراء الخاصه
كما تفضلت بالتاكيد انه دول القاره
الافريقيه الاطراف من الدول التي تعاني
تاثرت بالتغيرات المناخيه لحد كبير ولن
تسهم في هذه المشكله وانما تعمل في نفس
الوقت وابدت الاستعداد للاطلاع بمسؤوليتها
في
مواجهه
التطورات السلبيه المرتبطه بتغير المناخ
ولكن هي تحتاج ايضا الى الدعم في اطار
قدرتها على
التكيف وايضا اطلاعها بمسؤوليتها في فيما
يتعلق همم بالتخفيف اكيد انه قضيه التمويل
هي قضيه هامه قضيه الانتقال العادل همم
الطاقه الجديده والمتجدده همم حتى تستطيع
الدول الافريقيه ان تستمر
على مسارها نحو التنميه المستدامه نحو رفع
مواطنيها من
خط الفقر
والعمل على استمرار المساهمه الايجابيه في
الجهود الدوليه والدول الافريقيه هي طرف
اصيل في العمليه التفاضيه لها الاهتمامات
بكل قضايا المطروحه على جدول الاعمال
وتسعه
تكون المشورات والمفاوضات الحاليه همم
دائما
لامكانيه تبعها بمسؤولياتها ومهامها وان
يتيح المؤتمر بصفه عامه والفعاليات
المرتده به والمبادرات التي سوف تطلق
خلاله ومشاركه القطاع الخاص
وقطاع الاعمال ومنظمات التمويل الدوليه
والمجتمع المدني في همم طرح
الحلول في همم الاستعداد للنقل
للتكنولوجيا التي تتيح للدول الافريقيه
والدول الناميه بصفه عامه همم
التعزيز قدرتها على همم التعامل مع قضايا
تغير المناخ سواء فيما يتعلق بالتخفيف او
التكيف
واستمرار الاسهام الايجابي في المفاوضات
اا فيما بين الاطراف
هذا المؤتمر الصحفي من شرم الشيخ
لافتتاح او عاقبه افتتاح اعمال قمه المناخ
كوب 27 وتحدث فيه وزير الخارجيه المصريه
من الامم المتحده وزير الخارجيه المصريه
سامح شكري تحدث وقال ان هناك رغبه في
التواصل ارضيه المشتركه بين الدول
المشاركه ونعتبر مساله تعويض الخسائر
والاضرار انها تؤكد الرغبه في تحقيق تقدم
في قمه المناخ يقول ايضا وزير الخارجيه
المصري ان مسؤوليه تغير المناخ مسؤوليه
مشتركه ولا يمكن اقصاء اي طرف فاذا نواصل
معكم اذا المؤتمر في الساعات المقبله شكرا
لحسن متابعه مشاهدينا هو في امل